being a Harvard hero means that when i
leave Harvard I know I've left it better
than when I came honestly I'm a prime
means I work too much being the
Harborview hero means asking what can I
do to help you do your day to day and
you do it well but you're also trying to
find new ways to do it we're always
trying to figure out how we could do it
better how we can be more responsive to
our students I feel a little unworthy of
it because I feel like I work with
really amazing people I don't think you
can become a hero without having great
people around you I have lots of great
colleagues and co-workers who make me
look good
to me working at Harvard means not
having to make a choice between a
successful career and spending time with
my family it's a really interesting
place to be I am never bored you know to
be able to contribute to the best
educational institution in world history
it's a pretty cool thing like I think
it's wonderful that I work at Harvard
and I think it's just amazing it's it's
the place of legend allure it I wake up
every day and I kind of pinch myself
that I get to be among exceptional
people every day I come to work every
day surrounded by incredible people
every day I feel honored to be part of
that team it has meant the world to me
that I'm able to work here at one of the
greatest library collections in the
world I come every day happy back
working at Harvard means the opportunity
to influence the world oh to be a part
of a rich tradition and culture of
changing the world it's been home for me
I feel like I grew up here
he one of the most memorable occasions
for me was the honorary degree given to
Nelson Mandela I had huge goosebumps my
best days are the day we bring up a new
system and I see a student just sit
right down in front of it and it works
they're challenging days i think the
ones where we have the most challenges
also feel the most rewarding they're
probably the ones that I look back on
most fondly of well the day I found out
about this award would have to be up
there I would have to say I mean it's
been a long time since I cried at work
and I kind of did cry as a research
librarian I get all kinds of questions
and I think one of the funniest ones I
ever had was a student who asked me if
we had any raw data and I noticed a pen
underneath the desk in a classroom and I
bent over to pick it up and heard a
large tear in the back of my pants and
realized right away seven in the morning
and I've got a whole day to go through
with ripped pants I immediately called
my mother in law as most guys would do
right that's normal uh i crack myself my
steps to try to get my scarf and i found
out underneath a car and it was caught
underneath the tire and i was pulling as
i was pulling two football guys however
football guys came and actually lived
the car to get my scope out so i thought
i was i dressed up as Santa for my
co-workers and surprised them at the end
of the year in hand out candy canes and
got mobbed by a tour from Japan my
father came to visit me and he rolled up
one of the rugs and told the man sitting
at the reception desk that he was just
here to clean them and he walked right
out the front door with a rug over his
shoulder I said dad you can't you're
going to get me in trouble ardina the
time came up to me and she told me how
well one of my projects was going over
with the faculty I think her word she
used was none of them have complained
about it well there was the day the lady
forgot her shoes I don't maybe I
shouldn't I don't know the president
might not know this but someone came in
to meet with her once and it was during
the winter and it was dreadful and she
wore boots she had no nice
news ah so we happen to wear the same
size it seemed like a logical thing to
do so she she wore my black suede pumps
into the president's office they say ooh
Harvard they say oh you must be very
smart have it that's where they got all
those wicked smack kids are often they
say you must work with amazing students
they will ask if I can maybe get them a
job I think they want to know if I go to
school here if I'm a professor here the
first reaction i think people ask is it
do i teach there when I tell people I
work at Harvard Medical School they
assume I'm a doctor I don't correct them
exuberant energetic joyful dedicated
committed green can do helpful
enthusiastic determined and nadine
dedicated friendly lively awesome
committed jack of all trade call me to
determine committed dedicated team work
helpful collaborative determined hungry
connects lane is that allowed are we
sticking with the one word